we might be drunk
we might be drunk as
long as we are hanging out you know we
might be drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
are we starting up yo we're starting up
baby i'm already hard
hey we might be drunk it's the middle of
the day
here in a steamy manhattan it's a
nightmare out there
93. it's a soup this is do the right
thing weather
yes this sticky right radio rahim is
blaring the
the ones and twos or whatever that is
and uh
yeah nightmare danny aieo is throwing
people through a pizza
say yellow hi ellos
i never knew how to say it to be honest
well this ain't going to cool you down
but maybe the ice cream
oh what do you got here
hi wes whiskey campfire it's it's a salt
lake
uh it's it's from par it's park city
utah a guy
in salt lake gave it to me and by the
way if you're giving us liquor after the
show i really appreciate it but just
send it to the studio here because i'm
not checking bag
good point good point so you did check
this no no no they send it to me from
the club but i feel bad asking them to
do that yeah it's a probably a
28 uh fedex fee might have been they
kept the tag on so it's a little more oh
a little bit of a passive aggressive
move but uh you know i get it
oh look at it go on that white icy
globe we got the round balls of ice
there
oh baby don't leash just like lance
armstrong
and hitler we're two heroes
that's really good oh my god what's this
high west whiskey i also think it's a
cool bottle like we're making our own
whiskey it's cool to look at other like
how they package this stuff and look at
that they got the indentation in there
too it's like the
really the old west style class wow utah
real real rangy out there you know it's
it's another you can always see that
mountain
what is that mountain called i think
it's in park city
it's that big one oh in the distance man
i
remember driving once from vernal utah
not bragging i played vernal utah
infernal it's like oil town there man
yeah so you know oh by the way it put me
in the honeymoon suite it was like that
talk about passive aggressive
i feel like we got you a bigger room i
walk in it's like a heart-shaped hot tub
oh yeah actually this is a pathetic room
to stay in alone i know right
but they're so cool it's very like la
what do you call it like a logi
it's all very wooded so logi i love that
[ __ ] we drove from vernal to
salt lake and it was like true detective
country yeah you're looking at the side
you're like they're like tents on the
side of the road you're like this is
there's some meth going on oh no doubt
about it white
people love meth we love meth and uh
heroin
you by the way left out the part of the
story last week that i hear about from
salaccus that the reason you were so
hungover
needed knifev oh yeah is because you
accidentally took what
possibly fentanyl what are you thinking
that's why i didn't bring it up
well thanks a lot what am i your mother
oh
i don't know my mom says that um
but yeah you know it was that was it the
green hulk that's what the kids call in
the street they also call them totem
poles because they're long and thin
and because you wake up in a repair
underwear
yeah exactly jesus why would you take
that man
why are you taking pills from strangers
i they said what do you want in the
green room and as a goof like in the
ryder i said tequila
some fresh fruit and i need a xanax
every now and then just to crash because
that club gave you
fentanyl well it turns out the uh the
host was a was an ex-addict
and he was a real bad one at that he was
i used to pop three of these a day and
go to the the [ __ ] strip club and all
that [ __ ] so
he was like this is nothing and i think
that's why you gotta bring your own
opener i know
and not take pills from strangers yes
yeah well he thought i was some kind of
like
drug maniac i guess so he was like oh
i'll give him the good stuff
but uh this [ __ ] i flushed him
immediately
i still made my shows by the way next
day i know but this is not something to
be proud of that you can
you can bounce i mean a little cool but
look it's like it's like your joke about
being the functioning drug right
right yeah yeah it was a bad move and
boy i've slept for a good
17 hours and they were my friend it was
like weekend at bernie's it was dragging
me around san antonio
andrew youngblood thank you speaking of
some native american
you didn't know there was going to be a
sopranos movie i cannot believe it
you're like
one of the biggest sopranos guys i know
i'm a huge fan i just
uh it i missed i've been off the
internet a little bit more you know just
trying to
regroup and the whole thing but uh the
saints of newark the many saints of
newark yes great title
oh hell yes sally yeah it's his son is
playing him
oh wow dude if you see the trailer it
came out
i just saw it today the mannerisms
the face wow it's pretty did you see it
sally
no not yet it's crazy i love when they
do didn't they get ice cubes son
or ocean yes yeah it was great he was
great
he looks just like him that's good but
this is weird this guy's son is
his dad is dead and also it's like
you're playing a character that is so
iconic as your first role
big shoes i know you are playing your
dad in the other one but it's like i
know my dad i can just you know
yeah but like you're you're mimicking
tony soprano that's insane yeah and
and you know the eyeballs are going to
be on you and everybody's going to want
to [ __ ] on your performance because it's
not him
people always did hate change but i
guess it's the closest you can get
and they hate any sort of like origin
story that isn't
yes this is cool because it's like well
it's like you have the superhero origin
stories always the first superhero
movies
but when the sopranos it's the the show
was already out this is
this is the origin story so maybe you
get some built-in goodwill could you see
tony struggle and [ __ ] i don't know
can we see the kid or the son he's
probably not a kid at this point
you know he died the tony died or
scanolfini died at like i want to say 54
or something i think i think younger
younger 49 we drink a lot
yeah i think we just did this in the
podcast he died in rome
like he had a big meal and got
shit-faced and died i mean it just goes
to show you
fat is dangerous so is fentanyl from
strangers
it's bad to be overweight you took drugs
from a guy you didn't true but i won't
do it again
please don't i don't want to [ __ ] do
we we might be drunk alone
is going to be a depressing podcast you
shouldn't drink alone
yeah you're right good point good point
i'm here to stay and uh you can't stop
this ticker i'll tell you that right now
but i already love the look it already
yeah well would you just play the
beginning just so you see okay just play
the very beginning man
and look you want can you get it on
there is this
yeah oh oh you're pulling up on here
yeah
i don't see it yet do the thing matt oh
he can't do it ah
come on oh oh no oh they got the phone
boot is that him yeah oh yeah i can see
it
hey
wow yeah yeah definitely
it kind of looks and sounds like yeah
yeah all right that was it i just want
to show you that
oh my god this looks amazing i'm already
hooked i wonder if i can talk
i love that 70s gritty film look
newark man and newark whitney houston
and uh
damn john bernthal is in it and uh that
dude who played hemingway and midnight
in paris is uncle june
ah he's you know a guy from house of
cards yeah he's great great
that's great i guess june died um
junior yeah no junior doesn't die no i'm
the real like the the actor oh he's
alive so why wouldn't they have him
oh cause he's an origin young yeah yeah
it's like
that always kind of bugged me about
better call saul that they're doing like
it's before
but that actor who's playing mike is old
as [ __ ] yeah he's like a badass but he's
like gotta be like 80. he's like [ __ ]
you up
well nothing worse than the irishman
fight scene that was embarrassing
humility i mean just de niro like with
[ __ ] tits you're like
deniro it's weird to see cause deniro
was always just badass
just because he was badass i mean like
raging bull aside obviously he's
obviously
big in that movie but like you see him
like a later
and like goodfellas he's scary because
he's scary yes
not because he's like grip intimidating
yeah and then not to mention you spend
millions of dollars on that facial
recognition with the old and the special
effects
but then you can't perfect like a a
curb stomp kick also i said on twitter i
said it was the fakest fight since jesse
smallett
that was uh yeah that must have sucked
for jesse smilet i heard the
the cops called his performance uh
wooden and
not convincing at all when it came in
yeah those were those are dark time that
was what a weird story that was his
sister's still working
oh good she's in she wasn't like birds
of prey and oh yeah that was a pretty
cool movie that poor lady i mean the
questions like you're his brother whoa
what's he doing now was he was he full
of [ __ ] as a kid you know like all the
questions must be a nightmare his
imaginary his imaginary friends must
have been pretty rude
yeah they were all racist what uh so
what's
how where were you on the road this
weekend where the hell was i
oh levity live how was it it wasn't
great
good club mike or john john great
manager good people there good staff
i basically i got heckled the whole
weekend what yeah you know it isn't a
mall
small and you hate to say it but you'll
always be in a mall but good club and
comic should work there
right food's great john's great
everything was great
but uh just coming back to your house
every night is great it's a 37 minute
drive
beautiful but who's opening sean murphy
the great sean murphy
he's funny man super funny great guy he
got heckled and i have it on
on my phone i'll show you later he
snapped on a lady
i've been working with this guy for
years i've never seen him raise his
voice i've never seen him being polite
snap wow it was wild he was like when
mark gets up here you better shut the
[ __ ] up and i was like
oh my god it was like dad and a
sleepover energy you know
i got work in the morning god damn it it
was fun to see your dad snap
no not mine really oh my god mine
snapped so rarely that when he did i was
kind of like oh this is kind of exciting
oh really
yeah my dad was like the hulk it was
like zero to 60.
one time i was leaning back in a chair i
love to lean back and goes if you fall
i'm going to kill you and i was like i'm
not going to fall and i fell back and
the chair snapped like when i hit the
floor it broke
and he was like god damn he picked this
two pieces of the chair up i was like ah
he's so dull oh my god i [ __ ] myself the
barrett move of grabbing the wrist was
always scary
when they grabbed her because you know
my parents didn't hit me or anything but
my dad would when i was in trouble
they'd grab the wrist and like ah
yeah yeah you're hurting me
it's like when they say the cuffs are
too tight that was the fist the wrist
yes my dad would go back of the neck
because he wanted to hit me but he
didn't
want to hit me you know so he would do
the back of the neck like i'd be in the
tub and he'd be like
which is also weird because you're naked
you know what's funny too it's like
you're
hitting a kid in a movie is always so
[ __ ] up yeah but in the simpsons it's
the funniest [ __ ] ever
every time he chokes the kids so true
that's so true you're right
why is it i it's a cartoon and i get in
the tongues going wow you know
but if you saw that in public you'd be
like we got to call the police yeah
that's a good point
yeah [ __ ] beauty of animation beauty
animation
what uh so wes nayak just every delayed
shows were hell
yeah and i had to get a tape for a thing
and they're just like yeah i just filmed
the set and i
i got the tape but it's just full of me
i called a lady a [ __ ] and i flipped
out on this
freaking guy he was like a guido guy and
i was like you [ __ ]
phony whatever and like i just went off
on these people you ever get worried
that in like
all it takes like one nut with a gun to
just be like
because some of those markets you're
like i think when i'm playing like taxes
or something like
some people when you have guns yes
that's true yeah i love a club with a
metal detector oh yeah
phoenix lot big open carry oh how about
oh yeah sf they have the metal detector
when you walk yeah that's nice i love it
yeah i love that too uh what was i gonna
say
oh you heard that old seinfeld story
where he he's getting heckled by a guy
and he goes i'm just gonna stand here
this is like in the 80s
i'm going to stand here until they throw
you out and the guy just
nobody comes and sam was like you're
going to throw this guy out or what
and then he's looking to the side like
looking at the security and a bottle
whiz over his head
and breaks on the on the brick at the
improv
wow and he goes okay and he puts the mic
in the stand and leaves
and he's in the back like ready to chew
out the manager
he's like why do you throw that guy out
he threw a bottle at me what the [ __ ]
and they go you better get the [ __ ] out
of here it turns out it was a mob guy
wow yeah so pretty crazy damn
i ran off stage once in bridgeport
really did i ever tell you this dress
factory
no uh bijou theater i might even saw
this on the pod who the hell wait
i can't wait no i just it was one of the
things where this guy just kept
going like every other joke heckled me
every other joke to the point where i
was like
you're a dumb i just like i put him down
in every clever way possible we're 25
minutes into this point i can't keep
putting you down so i got to the point
where i go
you're a [ __ ] neanderthal you're a
[ __ ]
you and then he gets up and i was like
and you're the largest man i've ever
seen
in my entire life he's huge he's like a
[ __ ] linebacker and he's running
toward the stage
but you know and it's like that seinfeld
thing in your head you're like well
someone will get him away
he's standing right here and i was like
i don't think anyone's coming whoa he's
right here i was like [ __ ] the [ __ ] i
ran out
and i hid in the green room and it's
like it went to the it was to the point
where like
uh this woman comes in like locks the
door he's banging hitting the door
what yeah and she i was like are you
gonna throw them out she's like she's
like you have to go back out there i was
like you gotta throw i'm not gonna go
it was like thud and i was just like
yeah they didn't do [ __ ] i had to just
kind of like
we like waited it out wow yeah
man we we it was like when you wait that
out it's like maybe
someone was like he's not going to come
back out unless you leave so he waited
outside for me by the way too
we went around like yeah it's hilarious
when people
the woman by the way said if you don't
go back out that you're not getting paid
like
when when people say the show must go on
it is financial
yes completely i had no attachment to
that crowd
right he [ __ ] booed me as i had wow
yeah true story i [ __ ] on the crowd i
was like [ __ ] this crowd
i'm not going back out there the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that screw them i hear the
loudest booze ever i'm holding the
cordless mic
in the green room so they just hear me
[ __ ] on them i have to go back
out and finish the show oh my for the
people i just insulted
wow that's a battle a badge of honor
right there yeah it was
not good oh that second half was somehow
worse than the first but
i i would imagine i got paid you got
paid baby did the guy
was the guy out there again or yeah he
was but we snuck out the back
holy hell yeah see this is what's
beautiful and
horrific about stand-up it's the truest
it's they call us the warriors of show
business and that's why that [ __ ] ain't
happening at les mis
well then you hear about like the bill
hicks road stories you're like well ours
compared not
true they're not even close like he's
running towards like the car
it's like it's like a mob with a torch
chasing him you know in arkansas
it's like deliverance he's like every
road gig is like a windows getting
broken with a crowbar and they're like
go go right right exactly so
larry miller's got that great story
where he's bombing at a
at a school attendant what do you call
those things uh when the school gets
together
pta no assembly thank you
at the big assembly in the gym and he's
bombing and they were raising money for
some kid who died and he's bombing his
bombing he's like jeez
what the hell this this set's about as
funny as a house fire
turns out the kid died in a house fire
so they stormed the stage and he's like
and he's running the car he was in the
middle of nowhere to just get in his car
it was one of those things like the
opener dope through the window
and his legs are hanging out while
driving you know oh like
miller's voice too is perfect for that
sarcastic i love his he used to have
that bit where he's like how about these
couples that break up and get back
together
yeah yeah he's like it's like it's like
taking rod and milk out of the fridge
and be like oh this is terrible
maybe later so like that delivery is so
perfect his old stand-up set you're like
[ __ ]
he was good he's a beast really good
club comic uh and a hell of an actor by
the way
he's got 10 things i hate about you he's
great he's great on curb
curb the palestinian chicken episode one
of my favorite apps by the way
and dude he has the other bit too about
when people break up he has like the
classic
breakup bits who are like the ones who
are like you'll never find anyone like
me
has anyone ever broken up with him and
been like do you have a twin
just classic old school great jokes i
love love
the signature bit which was like the uh
the drinking guy
at the end of the night he's like all
right i'm gonna keep drinking but if i
go to bed now i'll get six hours then
you have eight more shots all right if i
go to bed now i'll get four hours and
then you guys stay up all night
great [ __ ] i was just in tampa and they
told me he would walk in the club
and go this is what comedy has made
just like he sniffs it like he's that
old school that he's like yes
this this room works that does have a
scent that room
yeah it does have that old comedy
beer-soaked wooden
smell that's just the owner that's true
well uh yeah man i was in raleigh all
weekend and yeah man is that a great
club great right
they were losing that room they might be
we'll see but man
ah they'll figure it out you know it's
got some problems it's three stories to
get up to the bathroom so
good point i mean it's like literally
you know gary veeder's opening for me
i'm like [ __ ] he's got two bits left
he takes a while with these one-liners
because i make it to the third story
run back you like time and [ __ ] yep yeah
but uh no
killer uh killer room classic
killer and that's one of those cool
towns that no one really talks about but
that's a good
town they got tons of [ __ ] to do there
it's like a sleeper town where
it's not pretentious the people are fun
they're just lit it's not too expensive
they're just happy there
amazing i mean dude i love raleigh
it's a great great gary and i went to
this restaurant called a place at the
table
if you know if you don't know if you
live in raleigh hit it up i'm sure you
know it if
if it's in raleigh it's a five-star meal
but if you can't afford the meal they
say pay what you can
what it's for the community the
socialist restaurant yeah well and it's
it's
they just want to help people so people
who the owner i talked to and he's like
yeah we think people should be able to
eat well who don't have the means we
want to be a place
that's good for the community it's
incredible it's kind of moving
yeah that is moving but here's the
clinker how do you
have the money to do that unless you're
rich he's got to be loaded this guy who
opened i don't know i think they
they can i don't know the yeah i don't
know the system i it would not work in
new york there would be a lot of people
who are like oh i got
no money yeah exactly a lot of starving
artists a lot of homeless
drug dealers whatever the meal was
incredible
that's great i mean i i assume you paid
yeah of course we paid full price yeah
you got it but then uh
yeah we had a great great meal and uh
[ __ ] so many i mean this is a crazy
story i'm in raleigh
i go to the ymca you know the uh i love
a good wreck
there's something i mean look you might
get a staph infection you might not
but you might also work out pretty damn
cheap that's pretty cool that's true
there's a lot of wet seats
at the y where you sit on the bench
you're like ah i've definitely taken a
dump at a rec
center and i've had people be like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind
and i'm like oh yeah that's gross yeah
well come on
it's all part of the community yeah i
don't mind it whatever so yeah i go
you just pull it mad do you just pull up
the village people like y
m c and that's stupid connected
that was the most obvious connection
ever and i wow
uh half a glass of this already hitting
me i guess and pride happy pride
happy pride to our gay brothers and
sisters yeah
you know uh i'm in
i'm in the la i'm doing laps in the pool
i'm swimming
the guy next to me comes out of the pool
he's an epileptic
seizure it looked like a fish flop and
it was so terrible he's like
they have to call the ambulance we'd all
run out of the pool
and i felt guilty too because i had an
exercise in weeks because of my
neck yeah so it was the best i felt
physically in like a month and a half
and this poor guy
you know and you're like i can't help
you i feel too good i don't want to pull
anything
wow like yeah horrible whoa
oh man they said he was okay i went back
the next day and they said he was all
right was he in the water
no he got out okay thank god thank god
the [ __ ] thing is like i'm looking
this guy
before he had it and he's you know he's
in better shape than i am
yeah this guy's got a great swimmer body
just look at a guy like all right look
at him go he's fast
yeah you know i kind of go slowly in
there i just do my thing but he was
cruising
yeah and then this happened it has
nothing to do with your fitness
obviously i guess not i guess i guess
he's just epileptic
or did something trigger it i don't know
then i talked to another guy that could
be dehydration
damn man i guess uh i i hate to say it
but i wonder if that's a good calorie
burner
yeah because you figure you're using
your whole body every muscle is tense
you probably burn like
10 000 calories in two minutes
i don't know give give that a goog salad
i was thinking of like what about an
epileptic uh
fish how do they get out of the water
they're just yeah
good point
epileptic fish great punk band
[Laughter]
but yeah oh yeah i heard he's okay thank
god terrifying thing to see
man just i'm just glad you didn't pull
your phone out that's what most people
would do in that situation that's
i remember one time i was at a club and
a comic
had a bit of a meltdown and uh at
standard new york and he basically
uh he basically got in the crowd was
being pretty rude and
the guy on stage puts the mic down and
does this oh like [ __ ]
like the matrix yeah get the [ __ ] over
here let's go
and right it was going down the host is
a guy who knows you know
pretty pretty loudly talks about how he
knows judo is i'm like
this guy could break it up he's kind of
a big guy i'm like hey man you should
like do something
yeah and he goes yeah takes his phone
out and starts
[Music]
[Applause]
do something means break it up be a
[ __ ] human yeah
it goes both ways because i was on
mcdougall the other night and i saw
two girls like going at it fighting and
uh
eventually they started throwing
haymakers you know girls are just
whipping out giant swings and pulling
the hair and
one girl was getting the best of her and
as a guy you're like
what do we do here and everybody's
filming it everybody's filming there's
like probably 50 people on the street
in a circle filming it and they're
hitting cars and falling into the street
the car
the traffic's stopped and i was like can
you believe these [ __ ] idiots just
filming this [ __ ] that is what's wrong
with our society and i went home
it's like i didn't do anything either i
just didn't film it but i thought i was
better than them i could have stopped it
you are a little better a little bit a
little bit filming it is
like it's one thing to do nothing but to
just go in there and be like i'm going
to use this for
likes yeah that is shittier it is shitty
but that would i
guarantee that was a hit on world star
because they were really going at it
like
slamming her on the hood and [ __ ] but a
guy an enter what do you call those a
delivery guy on a bike
stopped and stopped the fight got back
on his bike and kept going
damn [ __ ] uh that's what it takes
well that's what it takes you're the
only one who wants to step in there is
the one who doesn't have to work in that
moment
right it's either this or i gotta work
yeah but pretty noble to be like i'm on
the clock
you [ __ ] idiots are all drinking and
eating at a restaurant and i stopped
fixed the problem and kept going to
deliver this [ __ ] pad thai
uber beats yes there it is maybe he uh
man remember that mcdonald's five stars
all right sorry
he had but dude they had that mcdonald's
that used to be on west third street
they would be fighting oh my god that's
where like half of world stars videos
must have come from
definitely what is it with that
mcdonald's i think it's just an
amalgamation of all the drunks the
subways right there
there's like homeless people there's uh
like drag queens were in there it was
he used to write in there you and i are
yeah we remember we meet there to write
sometimes because we
cause mcdonald's coffee was like i was
like all right solid coffee and it's
cheap and they had a second floor
and then yeah we could hide in there
right dude late at night here it is you
know what west village is also becoming
low-key
times square that goes couple blocks
good point and time square is like
you know yeah at night you get some
loons yeah a lot of characters up there
that's a great point you're right
especially with broadway not happening
so there's no tourist to shake down so
it's coming back though god it's coming
back do you are you gonna
do any you know i really want to see his
book of mormon i've never seen he's
never seen it we should go together we
should go
we'll do it we'll do it we might be uh
culture that'll be our
bonus i love it i love more of this i
know this is dangerous i got three
three sets tonight i don't sets
i was at shows and sets and i had shits
my parents uh went and saw a book of
mormon and they were like it was
filthy yeah they're like we liked it we
like it but geez louise
man they're geniuses the south park guys
oh my god
talk about doing it their way i know no
better social commentary than south park
because again the animation
i feel you just go for it i think the
south park movie is
a top five comedy for me of all time for
sure the
uncut or the team america uncut uncut
both good team america's really good but
uncut is like
to me like a masterpiece and it all it's
it's
refreshing as a comic to see these
geniuses be that
silly and [ __ ] up like they'll do 20
minutes on farting
yeah and it's still great oh uncle
[ __ ] that was the whole song
yeah it's all very low brow but yet
smart at the same time
going to war about and going to war over
a movie about two guys singing about
uncle [ __ ] is the funniest [ __ ]
like it's incredible yeah yeah i love
those guys anytime i see them
interviewed i love them even more they
rule man
yeah they're the best what uh shout out
to lin-manuel
miranda by the way yeah he's going
through it right now and
he who's done more for broadway than
that guy and
it's a good fight you know what though
it's like they go after people that they
think will get because they do it with
tarantino and he's just like oh i
disagree
but when you do with lin-manuel miranda
he goes he sucks just weekend
i know i'm sorry i said don't give in
you've done you've done so much cool
[ __ ]
yeah and then because eventually you're
going to lose this guy
and then then what are you stuck with
you're stuck with [ __ ] uh
you know old whitey yeah so don't push
the
the good ones away i mean
it is what it is people people it's
currency to them
currency i mean just who cares that's my
thing it's like
if you if you feel bad apologize if you
don't don't that's
kind of where you're like nothing to
apologize for you did nothing wrong
um i think you're doing a lot of good
i'm a fan
i think yeah i think miranda's uh he
changed the game
he's brilliant man um here here i got a
toast to make
yes and i feel we we haven't even done
it yet but i think we got to do it man
guy who helped both our careers uh-oh
conan o'brien
oh great one great one how many times
did you do conan
eight i did it six and i had i had a
ninth on the books but the pandemic
just incredible ass yeah that's that's
that's 14 appearances between the two of
us that's pretty good
yeah he let you be yourself nobody else
would really trusted us like he did or
jp buck the
the booker great jp buck who who booked
the show was a producer who uh
i mean there's no one easier to work
with than jp buck no
he's he's a great guy he was so damn
so damn good at giving notes so many
people give you notes and you're like
all right well you know but i was never
annoyed his notes always made sense to
me completely
and he worked with you he wasn't just
like this is not good he was like
i don't know about this for the show
we've heard something like this before
it was always
good critical notes it wasn't just like
i don't like this or this is too
offensive
and also the show was on tbs so you
could be a little looser than say
nbc or cbs totally a lot of these
bookers are like
i'm like is this really necessary i know
you remember uh
you know seeing some bits i love get
butchered
yeah but i remember the only note i
remember i remember jp once gave me a
note and he said uh
you can't wish cancer on someone on
conan's national stage
i was like that's a very reasonable
that's reasonable uh i had a bit where i
told someone i hope you get cancer
was that the milestone
yeah but it was like one of the lines i
said i hope you get cancer and i say
treatable like it was the whole thing
where i'm like i pull it back a little
but i think just
i mean damn dude look at that you dabbed
your
conan that was that was that was you
that was
i think you were the first of any of us
to do late night uh-huh and that
appearance i remember we were in shock
that you dabbed your
you killed your at your debut i was
terrified and it went
well enough that i had a little
confidence that i was like why not just
keep being funny i remember thinking
that he's a funny guy
i'll keep being funny what could i do
and i just took the tie and you feel i
felt so silly standing next to him
you know the whole like thanks everybody
good night
you have to wave i was like [ __ ] it i'm
making another joke that's where the
kevin hart thing came from like why not
just say
another joke yeah he's uh
he's such a you know what's great about
conan is he knew when to be straight man
and he knew when to take over his
instincts are as good as any comedians
i've ever seen and you know a lot of
comedians i've heard be like
oh letterman's my guy let him i i
respected letterman so much but he was
never my guy
conan was kind of always my guy because
we were a little younger my brother was
obsessed with conan's
yeah we love the simpsons yeah the
simpsons
yeah he's our age more of our age group
yeah
he was so smart but he never like he
never went up there like i'm smart
yeah like you would never know that guy
went to harvard if he didn't
it's like greg geraldo you never would
have known he's like a harvard guy
unless he was like oh he went to harvard
yeah it's cool that he didn't like wear
that
that's so true and he would take a bit
like look at bill burr who does better
panel than bill burr on conan or norm on
conan
i mean he lets you shine and there's
some amazing
stuff on youtube with with the panel on
conan so
give that a look i wish we could have
done that i wish to do a sign off
the what did you listen to his sign off
i didn't see it i didn't see it he
actually said something
what you just said which is i tried to
live in the nexus of
uh stupid and smart
i mean that's what it was i mean the
silliness of that show i mean i remember
the walker texas ranger wheel well he
would just he would just keep pulling it
yeah the whole gag was just
like look how shitty this show is yeah
that was the whole gag
and it kept killing you like did you
show any random clip of this shitty show
yeah and he would just keep doing it he
had max weinberg he had
you know the masturbating barry and andy
richter director
it was great i mean andy richter just
picked this spot so well in that show
yeah
it was a classic late night show and
like look he'll
everyone's like he's not dead and like i
know but like give us a minute this is
what on in the air for 27 years yeah
yeah yeah
i watched it in college i mean i love
the show and i love him and i love that
he had guys like us on and
a lot of late night hosts don't care
about having stand-ups no
i mean still there some of them leave
when you're when you're done
yeah for sure for sure he was always
nice and uh
you come into the green room sometimes
you come to your dressing room to give
any good stories like
chatting with them after a set yeah well
why chat one before once and it was me
vekione and a couple other guys i can't
remember but i had like a full
comedy green room going where it was
like a real hang and we were all eating
the cookies and
conan came up and he was just like hey
you [ __ ] comics are always
mooching and this and that and he was
zinging and zanging and like
totally owned the room and you could
tell he's he's uncomfortable he's like
an
awkward guy which i i like more because
i understand that
and we try to talk to him and he would
kind of like you could see he's kind of
spazzing out a little bit like yeah
yeah i don't care but i'll listen and he
was sweet
but he was zinging and saying he made
fun of me i was wearing a bathrobe
he went off on that and like becky owen
is like this is [ __ ] awesome
he was always so classy and cool and uh
yeah i mean it's a big deal to that show
he had great writing staff too so shouts
out to like lori kilmartin yeah
brian kylie yes master the misdirect
killer uh andre de boucher oh yeah so
funny all those guys
and uh you know yeah i remember one time
i got off and i did a bunch of breakup
jokes
and he was like jesus christ are those
real and i was like oh yeah he got like
it was like a nice moment where he was
like you know
he was always supportive after the sets
like he'd always be like oh i like that
you did this i like yeah like he
kind of he likes jokes so much yeah he's
a joke machine i mean he wrote the
monorail episode the simpsons are
[ __ ]
so many of the best simpsons episodes
are are conan and
i mean todd levin yeah yeah he had
everybody
so many so many great pop yeah great
great group over there yeah he one time
i sat next to him
and he's doing like this oh yeah you
know he's trying to make conversation
the cameras are on
and i go i just cut him off and i go i
love that documentary you made and he
goes you watched that
well she was like yeah i watched i'm a
comedy fan you psycho but that's how
normal he was that he was shocked that a
comic would watch his
comedy movie yeah he uh
i don't think people know how much it
means to like not just do
a show that you watched as a kid and
loved as a kid and
provided so much laughter as a kid but
then the fact that he's cool and
supportive and
uh gets it and that you can kind of be
yourself like most late night sets they
really neuter us they
i mean yeah they just censor to the
point where it's like do you want the
joke to not be [ __ ] funny no
i know how scared are you like why did
you pick this job
i remember i did fallon once and they
made a huge deal that i said the word
cocaine i didn't say i do cocaine i just
said the word cocaine and it's like
what do we [ __ ] ate i know it exists
in the world
are you just gonna pretend it's not real
i hate that kind of [ __ ] like you can't
smoke on this tv show like
there's people who smoke and i will say
that fallon is very cool and like those
guys
they're very and like it's really just i
think it's standards and practices
yeah [ __ ] people with you know
up their ass they don't lose their job
over our dumb bit you know they're like
i know it's important to you but this is
my [ __ ]
sure we mean nothing and and i get that
but at the same
time like how old are we you know right
right i had to fight for two things on
conan and they both
hit i mean a fallon and they both hit
and i remember like feeling like
yeah you see you gotta listen to me but
it was boner and
piss yeah what was a bit i came up with
a bit but it was like uh i i was like
doing a bedwetting bit i used to wet the
bed blah blah and i would always have to
make up an excuse of the sleepovers and
like what happened here i'm like i must
have spilled a cup of piss
that's one of the jokes and it's like
they wanted me to say pee
and i'm like piss is the word it's it's
only funny with piss
and i did piss and i remember the roots
lost it and i was like
you see i'm gonna i'm in the clubs every
night doing it they don't listen to me
yeah we just want to be trusted right
that's all like it's tough so much
we do stand up a lot of us because we
didn't feel seen in a certain way
and you're not seeing us yeah so just
see us
wow yeah i think i think uh way to break
it down with
conan it was like you could always push
it a little bit which was exciting
yes it was exciting to push it it was
exciting to be our best conan memory
ever i was on a show once it was bill
burr
and bill hader with a guest that was the
show and it was my best set i ever had
on there was my second set
and uh man it was like one of the best
moments of my life
like the white man hall of fame i mean
it was it was [ __ ]
white and bird did a great panel bird
did his
caitlyn jenner bit oh i remember that
that was like a pretty incredible
episode to be on he did the bit of that
yeah he was like
that's just millions of people said i
love i love bruce jenner just give me a
minute
that was the bit and it killed the guy
shaves his beard i'm like oh you shaved
your beard but
this is a jet let me have a second with
it that's a great point it was great and
i followed that
and uh yeah it was it was a it was a
strong set i had
and to like walk to have bill on the
couch
yes watching it oh that was my best set
it was so cool it's insane because we
obviously look up to bill burr so much
and then uh
wow yeah it was a cool moment i'm like
in between the credits are one i'm just
chatting up conan and bill burr i'm like
wow what a [ __ ] moment
so uh that is a great moment in comedy
that that's like being uh
up to bat you know like uh mark maguire
is watching he's on the bench watching
you bet that's insane that's a huge
huge honor and just a great moment of in
time of comedy and bill hader was so
[ __ ] nice too i mean it was a cool
thing show to be and that was the thing
is like you know some of these other
shows like
uh colbert well they're like they film
like eight comics at once right
so the conveyor belt so it's a conveyor
belt so a lot of people don't know this
he's not in studio yeah right yeah it's
pretty heartbreaking it's pretty it's a
bummer yeah right like you want the
whole show
the whole experience you want to [ __ ]
have a right you want to bump into the
other guests in the hallway
you want to see you know like hey edie
falco nice to meet you have you met her
on the show i met her somewhere else
really yeah i met her on horus and pete
yeah the louis thing yeah
yeah but that's what i'm just throwing
out an example of like a an actor you
want to like bump into on a lady you
want the whole story
yes the conveyor belt thing it hurts a
little bit it makes us feel that it's
special and
guess what nights like this we're not
getting the bump
that we got like back in the day like
comics on carson the 80s
that changed your life this doesn't do
that much anymore we're doing it
because it's [ __ ] cool yes it's tv
you got a suit on
they fly out it's exciting it's a night
it's a fun night of comedy and you
earned it you do all these horrible
shows
and now you get some you get to own that
channel for six minutes
and then you're doing it with eight
other comics when i went i brought sally
there he brought his wife
we uh we we did it up we stole all the
green room goodies we got to eat after
love the green room goodies yeah we were
lucky enough to do colbert when it was
still
normal and then it became this conveyor
belt that was the first comic on colbert
that wasn't famous it was like seinfeld
bamford and then me
that's a feather on the camera that's
pretty cool but and it was good it
wasn't like one of my best sets so
i had i had moments on it for sure but
mine was weird yeah it wasn't like
i always did better on conan yeah well
you could be yourself i mean
if you got his handcuffed it's gonna be
half the uh half the profit
for sure you talk about geeking out i'm
such a queef
this guy drew a picture of us if you can
find this sally i'll blow you cause this
is gonna be a deep dive but some guy
drew us
as the simpsons characters i loved it
it's amazing i love that
i got a tear in my eye it's just so cool
because like you know growing up you're
like oh paul mccartney's on the simpsons
oh
uh de niro's on the simpsons whatever
and they would draw him and have his
voice
and i was like how cool is that and then
just
you could just go to that oh there you
go
yeah yeah all right i feel like we're
getting i'm getting too sappy here we go
or something yeah yeah let's do some
peeves man what do you got i'm all over
the row with peeves
one and this is gonna make oh look at
that is that up on the board
matt oh and come on it's joe liss uh
fat ass and then me they gave they were
very generous with my height you're way
taller than me both of you guys i don't
know why they made you chubby though
yeah they gotta give me a little gut
i'll take it for the uh for the height
and uh then they got you and the cool
jacket i i don't i usually have a five
o'clock shadow here i look uh i look
true
i look like a persian here
you're like the uncut gems uh stunt
double there
[Laughter]
i i i look like uh well that's the
jacket from one of my specials right
i got this yeah dude yeah i love that
jacket but it's like tough to wear a
jacket again that you wore in a special
oh yeah because they're like guys that's
all he wears right
trust me i know with that everything i
do people go uh same shirt i'm like yeah
i have six shirts
what do you want from me but uh you get
those suits soon
oh my god liberty and state
let's uh let's get those suits let's get
those suits that's what it's called we
got a new sponsor and uh we asked if
they'd give us seuss if we wore them on
an episode and they said yes
yeah they'll be a very uh high uh it'll
be a sweaty episode but we'll look great
i hope we get fat cat for that episode
that'd be a great premiering of the uh
the whiskey
so yeah all right peeve so i'm gonna and
subscribe to the channel we have a new
channel oh yeah well i i assume if
they're on this
they know about it yeah but just
subscribe make sure you subscribe to our
new uh we might be drunk youtube page
i'm gonna do a post tomorrow because i
post i tweeted it and i put it on my
stories but i'm gonna do a static post
because i don't i looked at the numbers
i was like
and i got some messages like hey where's
the episode i'm like
this will be good long term though
probably yeah for sure for sure we're
gonna take a hit in the beginning but
then it'll
come back but peaf
now this is gonna make me sound like a
real douche
and i'm nervous to even bring it up
uh-oh not really but
there's the channel uh
oh yeah that's a good look at this watch
this good-looking channel hey
select you subscribe well done there
fatty
all right hey folks
we might be drunk is brought to you by
good old honey
yes you know you do the online shopping
we're all hunting for coupon codes and
uh
saving money codes and whatever the hell
you got to type into that
search box we've all been there but
we don't know the code how you gonna get
a deal without the code
you gotta be in some vip club or private
room
not anymore we all shop online and we've
all seen that empty promo code
just taunting us well thanks to honey
you don't have to search for one anymore
honey is free
and the browser extension that scours
the internet for discount codes when
you're ready to check out honey
automatically applies the best one
instant savings honey has found its
customers over
2 billion bucks in savings supported by
over 30
000 stores online buy anything you want
from tech
gaming beer wine you know we love that
it's a great idea you can just get a
free code to save you some dough why
wouldn't you do it
get on it screw clipping coupons
i i just bought some shoes i used honey
found a nice uh
promo cut me uh cut me down quite a bit
so you should do it too if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out on free
savings it's literally free installs in
just a few seconds
save some dough and support this pod get
honey for free
at joinhoney.com drunk
that's joinhoney.com drunk
and get that honey baby
i got a real problem these days with
some language barrier stuff
okay i get it you know my my
grandparents are immigrants they're from
italy
and all this [ __ ] or whatever are you
getting an uber
he's not talking great he's from nigeria
i don't give a [ __ ]
but i go to my barber shop i've been
going there for
seven years they're not high end they're
not low and they're right in the gooey
middle
yeah i got a language barry at the
barber he [ __ ] my hair up look at this
[ __ ]
i think you look fine i don't know what
you think it's a little too tall on the
on the top
tall on the top short on the side so i
go well
if there's more to do why don't you get
him to snip the top well i had to get
out of there because he kept [ __ ] it
up and i was like
this is good this is good he was like no
i was like i think he was polish or
something
and i was like you almost sounded like
dice
learn the [ __ ] language that's what i
was thinking the whole time
so i go i like a scissor cut the only
time i like a clipper is
is around here and the back and he goes
oh yeah yeah and he just
dude i'm going to say it goes round i
was like what are you doing he's like
you said the the buzzer on the side i
was like no
i'm at the ear you psycho and uh it was
a whole thing
damn i'm the same way i just got a
haircut too oh there you go but you're
you're more like a sheep where you can
just shorten that [ __ ] you know
sheep not a sheep you're not a follower
you're just like that's more uh
you're more thick i feel like i'm more
stringy
you're more like round you can just
do the lamb [ __ ] lamb well you just
got a thick
mad you got like a full nerf i i yeah i
do the
the buzzers on the side and the scissors
on the top yes
yes that's a good move you didn't do the
scissors on top though here
i did i did but it wasn't enough and
then he's like i have to blend to blend
he only knew
he didn't know english there that's you
getting a haircut
with nick schwartz and doing it but yeah
uh
i'm not saying i'm getting his ass to
him
i got a wax yeah
sam at the barber but they're [ __ ]
struggling
two armenian men are holding me down
yeah that's what i picture
uh you're like i need a seltzer all
right
they have now like they serve booze at
some barber shop mine does well you kind
of want to be like
i can i can hold off with alcohol for a
20-minute haircut good point
one of the things where you're like i
get what you're doing but also it's like
not the place what am i gonna say
they're just buzzing it it's the hair is
gonna be in my cocktail yeah
this is maybe not the best place i just
think like there are some places we can
go without
alcohol right right i say as i drink
this in a podcast studio
well this is with friends but you're
right it's it's it's supposed to be this
classy like james bond uh cary grant
like you want a whiskey while you wait
i'm like
no it's noon i i like whiskey but like
you know what i want whiskey as a
[ __ ] dmv yeah that's what i get
[ __ ] up
now that's a bit now you're talking
that's a great point give me a whiskey
at the dmv the post office
uh any government office that's good
yeah
yeah but the barber i don't need i don't
need a whiskey
so yeah i think you got something there
but and then i feel bad he's like you
sure you sure you need to relax
i'm like no you just suck at cutting
hair but either way we got through it
then i tipped big because i felt like i
was a
like a big hawaiian there i know dude
i hate when they [ __ ] up and you're
doing it i'll still
yeah and then you have there's a mirror
so you get to see
the whole time that's me that's me the
seinfeld yeah
that's a great episode straight up dude
the edward scissorhands
you're watching yourself get [ __ ] it's
horrible
you do feel like a [ __ ] i'm like a
little [ __ ] i'm in the the smock like
man he's cutting it more i'm like man
i'm like you're [ __ ] up and then he's
like i don't know you said
clipper and i'm like yeah yeah you
[ __ ] up now i gotta
not even console your fat ass i used to
go to a place and i gave them a few
times and they kept [ __ ] it up and
now
it's tough they're in my neighborhood i
still see them but i go to another place
i'm not going back it does feel like
running into an x yes there's that thing
where they're just like
you look well and i'm like you too yeah
[Laughter]
all right what do you got what do i have
for peeves give me a good peeve
i had to get that out i got it today i'm
loving it dude
i might even go to another barber and be
like this guy [ __ ] me up this
might this might be more of like an
upsetting realization of being older
rather than a pee
okay for the week let's hear it
nightmares feeling realistic
ah i've had that my whole life when i
was a kid i felt like it was like more
like murder or
like you know like boogeyman type [ __ ]
now it's like a lot of my nightmares are
like they're so vivid
all of nightmares like uh i pocket dial
someone while i'm talking [ __ ] about
them
i'm like this is so real right and this
is like more of like ah this would just
be
you know it's [ __ ] it's everyday [ __ ]
it's everyday [ __ ] but it's also like we
were like ah
now i gotta mention this when i see the
guy like that's that's the level of
nightmare i have where i'm just like
oh just press end just press n but i
can't do it
that's funny your nightmares used to be
deadly and now it's just like
sitcom like awkwardness it's it's crazy
it used to be like my grandpa getting
like stabbed and then being like
you ever see that scene in fargo where
were the uh
[ __ ] spoilers if you never uh see it but
when the
old man gets shot and the guy he goes
like he's like right in the gut
you know when you're shot i used to have
that like my grandfather getting stabbed
you know
fargo by the way one of the best oh it's
on amazon for free right now you haven't
seen fargo
highly recommended one of the one of the
best movies in the last 20 years did you
have reoccurring
as a kid i have a lot of nightmares i i
i find that melatonin will give me night
yes yes maybe because we're so deep
finally deep sleeping and all all the
demons come out
embarrassing story i once told uh artie
lange told me he couldn't sleep and i
was like try melatonin he goes sam i'm a
[ __ ] heroin addict
point taken i'm sorry very sorry have
you tried stabbing oh my
oh can you look up uh i had a recurring
dream when i was a kid of
of going on a safari trip with my
parents and my grandmother and lions
chasing us
and then we all got chased off a cliff
as a kid i'm up talking like six yeah
i wasn't my my mind to like went on a
[ __ ] safari vacation that's where my
mind went but you are getting eaten by
animals
yeah it didn't end well and i must have
seen that in a dream oh
maybe run away from your own inner
strength what the [ __ ]
this can be a fear of taking extra
responsibility or a fear of being
successful
it can help be helpful to ask yourself
what is holding you back
dreaming of fighting with a lion and
dreaming i tried to do a bit about this
and never hit about how when you look up
your dreams like i had one that i would
just be
like surrounded by rodents that was a
recurring dream
like a tub interesting and one of the
things i saw that came up was like
you know changes in your life could be
occurring that's what it meant
and it's like could you get a different
delivery system
you know like exactly uh like it's
almost like if you're just getting
stabbed in the neck a bunch and they're
like
romantic possibilities away i know it's
the weirdest
uh way to deliver it yeah like the
wooden teeth means you're gonna be rich
like that's rich come on
what is that that's [ __ ] weird but
the brain is fascinating i mean there's
some deep caverns that we'll never
understand
yeah you know what i'm really [ __ ]
excited for
our whiskey man oh my god i'm with you i
mean this is this is giving me a
there's a problem this is really good
this is getting me excited i know i want
to drink the whole bottle
i got another pee for you hit me i got
one more too apple dude
apple the [ __ ] the company yeah
they're bugging me man my
something goes wrong with my i spent all
this money on this mac computer
and there's something wrong with it like
every week and i literally
call in for help and i was like oh my
touch bars
doesn't work and they're like all right
well we started like oh i already tried
they're like we'll just do it again so i
restart it and they're like
uh all right i was like yeah it didn't i
mean it still doesn't work
uh well that's uh we ran our test that's
all we can do i was like that's it
don't restart that's it you think i
could have figured that out
genius bar my ass like that's a bit of a
grandiose term for i have to go to the
store
that was all they had oh my god nothing
else over the phone
yeah what kind of schmucks are you
dealing with i'm home like three days a
week i'd like to not spend it at the
[ __ ]
apple store yes uh what a nightmare what
what's the problem what's what
maybe a touch bar you know you have the
touch bar now it just doesn't light up
anymore ah
well you can like brighten it yeah yeah
i like that touch bar
i like it too oh yeah you got to get a
new it's a first world complaint
they better give you a new one for that
a new one yeah i don't want a new one
it's my computer that's the other thing
that's true that's a big feature it
sounds like the lights out or a wire's
not connecting yeah that's a big big
that's like your headlights not working
or something yeah your car is true
oh man that's a faulty uh you got
screwed there i got screwed but yeah i
just got this computer like the end of
last year too
did you get the warranty yeah oh i do
the warranty i never get the warranty
you're
dangerous i don't have health care
either so yeah but that's [ __ ] insane
you're making a lot of money and you
don't make you don't have healthcare
it's just that paperwork i don't want to
do you're an idiot
you don't have you don't have healthcare
and you take pills from strangers are
you out of your
[ __ ] mind i'm gonna get a credit card
soon if that makes you you don't have a
credit card that's another one mark all
right hold on a second i'm gonna get the
american experience
not getting the warranty is the
condomless sex of buying
appliances done that quite a bit as well
well let's
take one thing at a time all right all
right i mean those days
they're not condomless sex because you
don't get new computers if you
don't get a warranty good boy but you do
get a virus
that guy who killed himself so um
you need health care i know i'm gonna
get it it's not that expensive and you
make a lot of money
i know but i could just go to the uh the
clinic there the
the the why did you get hit by a car ah
true you could wobble in what do you
call that place
you have like this you have this like
something care
something some people have survivors
guilt you have survivors arrogance
that's what you have urgent care it's
the only department i'm arrogant in
is uh i've fallen off that moped like
you wouldn't believe that's what i mean
you live recklessly and you don't have
[ __ ] health insurance
you can get called catastrophic
insurance
anything above twenty thousand dollars
that's when they start paying yeah i
like that yeah and it's cheap
can you walk him through this one day
that's a great name too catastrophic
insurance so it's so
grand you're [ __ ] nuts that's a good
thing you why you buy
[ __ ] antique bmws but you won't get
health insurance
i don't like blade either this is
[ __ ] abs like this is insane
oh yeah you live like an [ __ ]
you look like a huge [ __ ] that's i
need [ __ ] insurance
you need [ __ ] well this is like uh
this is like
he just wants this for the documentary
is what it is mark norman never had
health insurance
and then he bought another bmw it's just
going to make you look cool in like the
in the classic throwback if it helps
those aren't insured either
[Laughter]
we drove to jersey with no plates and no
insurance and
a car that really rent a car do you get
insurance no never that's a scam
that's a scam they know that's a scam
matt peters do you do you get
car insurance yeah you do solo queues
yeah you guys are all i get it for other
people's cars
your rubes scamming schmucks
we may be schmucks but you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like this is insane
ironically you guys are the marks all
right all right
don't put the crickets this is [ __ ]
amazing you're insane
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
what was that that was a heyo
rodney sound effect oh yeah there you go
uh oh i got one more p but that was a it
was a good little lesson there
uh i appreciate it fellas
another peeve you ever get somebody
giving you a gift
and then they tell you what to do with
it oh
i [ __ ] hate this girl for example
like well it started when i was a kid
with my grandmother she gave me this
horrific sweater and as a kid you don't
know where her grandma's sweater had
like a dinosaur on it
and i was like i hate the sweater and i
was like nine and my mom's like we're
going to your grandmother you should
wear the sweater i'm like well who's the
gift for
i gotta wear it around her now like this
is for her more than me
that was it the blue sweater up there
with the dinosaur on it that was me
six hundred dollars well that wasn't it
obviously
but uh that's a coach sweater but it was
like that i'm not i don't want to worry
that'd be hilarious if she got him a 600
sweater like the nicest gift the nicest
gift of all time
no but i looked like a special needs kid
i wanted a batman or something fun
you know what when you're a kid and
they're like wear this yeah it's [ __ ]
annoying yeah
i hated it and i you know i lived in a
black neighborhood i was in public
school i can't wear a dinosaur sweater
what are you kidding
so i had to wear it around her but that
was just the beginning now somebody gave
me a gift i'm not going to say what it
is because it was a nice
nice enough audience member brought a
gift and he's like
did you do did you do this with it have
you framed it yet i'm like
i don't know maybe i'll frame it i don't
know but like it's a it's like work now
now i got errands with the gift yeah now
i know what you mean where it's like
once it's tough someone gets you
something nice but then you gotta
mark is we all know he's not gonna do
[ __ ] like i get it i'm the same way like
yeah
like have you done this have you put on
the wall yet have you shown your friends
i'm like i don't know like
now now you're like keeping tabs on me
like this is now
worse than if i hadn't gotten the gift
and it's tough because you want to be
grateful and you want to be gracious and
all that but
come on what are you what are we doing
here no it's i'm just even with this i
was kind of like i i love this word
i'm not checking a bag i don't check
bags unless i absolutely have to
hate checking the stress of it like will
it come out
you know yeah oh my god have you been
there have you had that or it never came
uh i mean i had like an incident but i
did get it that night but it was
okay that was still scary even then
you're like [ __ ] cause it's how do you
control you
it just maybe i'll get it maybe i won't
kind of thing yeah terrifying i've been
there it's it's a nightmare
yeah it freaks me out i don't want to
yeah i don't i just don't want to
worry i like having everything there
even when you're at the gate and they're
like we need to put it under the thing
i was gary veeder and i fly to
laguardia they'll do things where you
like sometimes you just walk straight on
but you know the one where you have to
go downstairs yeah and then you're just
on the street
and laguardia you're like what the [ __ ]
is you're on queen's boulevard
it's ridiculous so you're like walking
with a with a rolly bag and like
i leave i'm like do i leave it here
they're like yeah sure i'm like sure
this is my [ __ ] i need i need more of a
confirmation
yeah sure exactly she said sure
like i'm like oh cool thanks yeah i'm so
with you i don't even
like putting it you know if you're in in
6d
and you sometimes you have to go back to
like 11
a to put it up you find a spot then you
run back to your seat i
i'm thinking the whole flight like all
right i got to get up and haul ass back
there and hall eyes back before anyone
gets up and
just that gives me anxiety pick that
seat so you could get off quickly
getting off yeah
is is huge man i hate the person that
tries to cut in front of you
i had a guy in i was in the [ __ ]
middle he's in the [ __ ]
window and he tried to get through me i
was like whoa whoa whoa you don't
[ __ ] get to just climb above me
good good for you i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] there's a kid who did that to me
and i was like this little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
a kid you let it slide but an adult
you're like i didn't let it slide
what the hell did you spank him i should
have
i just got angry i just was like what
the hell i get it
other people were mad at him too he
bumped another guy and the guy was like
what that people were turning on this
guy we should have just [ __ ] whaled
out yeah
street justice the delta variant it's
like the warriors but it's dealt the
comfort we're just [ __ ] beating the
[ __ ] out
dude i yeah the delta variant you know
delta's not loving that no
no corona's like finally we can sell
beer again
it is hilarious that they come up with
names i know i know still better than
the uh southwest variant
but we can't call it the united variant
because we'll never be united as a
country
you got that right a lot of division but
uh
my biggest moment in my life before
virginity everything
the lady goes you got to check your bag
there's too many
you know we have no more up room what do
you call that above ground above the
head
overhead overhead there's no more room
you got to check the bag it's like
i bet there's room there's always room
every time you guys say that there's
always room and she's like there's no
more room sir she's getting all you know
[ __ ] and i'm like i'm at this room
and she's like there's no more room and
i run past her and i get in the plane
and there's room
immediately and i throw the bag up she's
like sir she chased me i go
look at that look at it and she does a
deep sigh
and leaves wow the best moment of my
life yeah there's something about
planes now too they did a thing on a
flight recently i know if it was because
of covet or something but
the bathroom door was locked and she
goes i have to unlock it and i was like
well look at you look at the keymaster
right here
yeah what is that what is that you know
and then she did another thing
this happened recently when i was going
to the bathroom you know sometimes they
take like an hour to take off yeah you
have to piss like i drink a ton of
coffee in the morning
right i'm drinking by the way i just saw
an article if you drink like four cups
of coffee a day
great for your liver is that right hey
let's go
finally some good news with the liver
but uh i'm getting up and i'm like i'm
like you know
hour on the ground 25 minutes in the air
i get up to pee and she go the seat belt
signs are still on i go
are you going to stop me and she sits
down she goes no and i was like
well there you go exactly i have an old
bit about how
planes have turned into school you know
it's like you can't pee now you have to
ask to pee
you can't get up sit down here's snack
time it's like kindergarten all over
again
you take a nap yeah you take a nap and
then you hide your phone when she walks
by you know
it's all school again it is hilario you
know that the phone really doesn't
it's not a huge problem if we're going
by the honor code right
put it on airplane mode you're going to
trust all of us
really i know is this really taking down
the [ __ ] aircraft
exactly if it did we'd all be dead
because no one is doing that how'd the
plane crash
bob was playing words with friends in 4c
yeah ironically the word of the day was
uh you know nosedive
all right oh
wreck yeah yeah yeah that's good
that's good good show good good uh
you give me one cause i'm trying to
think of the name of this movie i
watched and i really enjoyed it um okay
i got a wreck for you
please uh nice luggage
ah yes i have this with me this bag dude
i just got this bag i love it
good looking well you know it's got this
little thing i can flip it on my rolly
bag
so i put it on top i roll it together
genius i've never gotten nice luggage in
my life even my rollie bag is like 50
bucks
yeah saying i'm i'm a cheap bastard with
that stuff but
my back was out so i was like there's a
few weeks ago i was like you know what
i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
bag i throw on top travel has never been
the same
i'm loving it dude no is this a tumi
that's the only luggage brand i know
it's tumi
what do you call this briggs and riley
oh i don't you know i don't like even
saying their names i feel like we're
giving a free plug yeah
yeah well yeah hey if you're hearing
this how about throwing us some more
free [ __ ]
yeah just plugged you who travels more
than comedians
and we'll keep plugging you because i
like your [ __ ] briggs and riley yeah
it's a good bag it's good wow
yeah a good bag really seems to kill all
right
it looks nice and it it feels nice it
smells nice
is that leather i don't know but it's it
is it's got all these little
compartments and i'll tell you
perfect for bringing booze and a laptop
like i bring to the mac store so
oh yeah and some biscoff cookies that i
got from my flight
delta delta i know it too well
oh there you go sally whale or a seal
you just throw
[ __ ] food out
he's got a balloon on his nose right now
well how about um
yeah what's your rack uh watch this
great documentary cell you might have to
do some uh some digging here it's uh
gay guy in the 70s he produced
grease the movie and i watched it on
amazon and i was like ah let me try and
i try to be a little open-minded with
documentaries
that's him the little guy down there
that's him
funny-looking guy greece is classic man
oh yeah well it was a broadway play and
he's like i bet this would be a great
movie
and he had ideas like that was that your
vocals break out that movie
well he was on welcome back cotter and
he was like this tv phenom
and they're like he'll be the guy he's
amazing in it so he's olivia newton-john
oh god what's her name uh the the other
woman who's
stalker channing isn't that yeah she was
probably 31 in that movie yeah playing a
high school
character classic what's the name of the
guy though alan carr
it was a great document about alan carr
this guy he
directed the oscars a bunch and the
failures he had so many failures and
they just kept going
and uh eventually died of cancer but big
coke head
that's it the fabulous alan carr great
doc if you just want to put something on
and
just the footage and like everybody
loved him he's got like clint eastwood's
got him in a headlock over here like old
hollywood stuff when hollywood was
hollywood like showbiz
he put grease on like he knew everybody
he was the guy to know
oh i'm gonna watch this for sure really
fun this looks great
greases will put him on the map but he
was a funny guy he was great on merv
griffin
greece was really pretty cool man i
loved it as a kid
yeah yeah a lot of good songs in there
yeah grease lightning and
[ __ ] i've got chills oh yeah
multiplying
and i'm lose
yeah no it was a good time and like you
know also it's like hilarious like
summer nights like all those songs are
like [ __ ] classics yeah
well the the whole point of it of the
grease thing was he grew up in the 50s
and it was like musicals and all these
jolly oklahoma and all this [ __ ] and
then the 60s and 70s were just like
nixon vietnam race riots martin luther
king
bobby kennedy and then so this was like
getting out of that wow yeah so it's
like fun and poppy
cute yes exactly so it kind of hit home
yeah it's just fun it's just completely
uh
it's a feel-good musical for sure oh
yeah there's a
fun to think now because he's gay isn't
that fun when you know somebody's gay
later
it's also interesting like yeah for sure
but it's also interesting to me like
this like you look at her in this
picture olivia and john like
she just gets him by dressing like kind
of [ __ ] like that's the whole i think
the moral of the story is that
she's like i was a good girl and then
she shows up she's like look at but tell
me about it
stud and you're like oh she's a [ __ ] now
they should be together this is perfect
right well he wore black now she's
wearing black so it all fits because
that was the whole thing he was like the
bad boy and then she's the cute
preppy chick and so he couldn't be seen
with her yeah and then she's like but
then he was like it was like the lyrics
you better shape up it was like
yeah you better be a man cause my heart
is said i know the whole [ __ ] thing
she's great man
oh yeah she didn't do much after music
career dude big tour and music act
really let's get physical physical
she's australian she hides it well
interesting
oh yeah shout out to australia man heard
about the second uh
wave what yeah corona yeah man
what i thought they were cle clear free
and clear or maybe that's new zealand
nah yeah new zealand what is new zealand
is that an island like i just put it
with florida
i mean uh i'm sorry i've been drinking i
pull it put it with us
those are the keys no wait i just put it
with uh
australia i mean is it the little
brother there yeah okay okay
but it's different how many people live
on new zealand
how big is it it's not that big it can't
be that big but i remember they were
having raves and [ __ ] in like
august and we were all jealous remember
well they their leadership
acted pretty damn quickly man yeah and
they did not let people come in yeah it
was pretty they
handled it pretty well is that it off to
the right the thing blinking
yes oh okay yeah so it's basically
australia
it's right there it's the staten island
of australia
let's be honest they've given us such
great things as the flight of the
conchords
i think peter jackson lives there
doesn't he oh
right right yeah yeah oh wow yeah it's
supposed to be
gorgeous i believe it the pictures are
insane
um
so they have a big booming metropolis
i wonder what their export the big
export is because australia's a lot of
trash let's be honest
i've never been have you been i did the
melbourne comedy festival and it was
it was wild and it's beautiful and it's
you know it's a real city but
i mean i think like 98
of the continent is unused because it's
just like
wasteland and desert and scorpions and
all that [ __ ]
so they just hung out by the beach and
it's a great i'm
butchering all this i'm sure some
australians furious right now
but uh yeah it's it's a wild place like
they booze it up
very asian i gotta go there i i the
problem is the money's gonna be stupid
for me to get in the flight that long
it's a hell of a flight i mean it's
literally a 12 hour time difference so
you're
completely upside down time wise that's
a classic a tell joke
that was their day their day apart i
called myself
i picked up the phone
[Laughter]
exactly classic yeah i was like remember
that movie insomnia with robin williams
i never saw isn't it in alaska it is
yeah the sun doesn't go down so he's all
[ __ ] up christopher nolan
is it i believe so wow not a great
picture it's not great
it's not great but it's it's pacino and
robin williams so you're like all right
i'm i'm on board pacino's great yeah and
romwe's just playing like a
is always great as a cop too that's like
oh yeah he's got the like the bags under
his eyes
he's got the voice yeah he's wearing
that leather trench coat
i'm just getting warmed up
oh yeah see if love is fun yeah yeah and
barking hot as [ __ ]
oh so hot that's a cool movie great
movie there it is yeah
but it was like that like i didn't know
where i was when i was and i would end
up trying to get drunk to like
get leveled and that didn't help so i
was a mess out there
damn i got to do i've never done alaska
me neither i have no interest in alaska
no i'm not against it it's just like i
just want to go places
yeah it's just we go everywhere we're on
the road every week what how are we
going to add [ __ ] i think this is the
winter
land over there it's just cold and
igloos and
oil pigs you know yeah i think the the
ratio to men to women is like 10 to 1.
i think one twelve to one something
crazy i don't wanna be anywhere with
that few women
yeah it's brilliant just for like the
barbaric aspect because yeah the women
who are there probably think they're the
hottest woman ever
every guy is corny as [ __ ] exactly
exactly it's gotta be tough a lot a lot
of big
egos on the women there i bet oh yeah oh
yeah they they probably look like matt
you know but uh they think they're cindy
crawford
which really dates me that does date
doesn't she have like a hot daughter now
she does i pull up the daughter
i think pete davidson's dating her isn't
she i think he was i think he was uh
smashing that cindy crawford that's
gotta be weird though when like the mom
is like
legendarily hi i know big shoes once
we've come full circle yeah she's pretty
oh
man look at that back to back jesus i'm
trying not to get hard here salutes what
are you doing to me
mom and daughter my favorite job that's
a good character the guy who like can't
see a hot woman without getting hard in
public
i'm at the funeral like get a little
dance out of here [ __ ] get out of the
room i got a boner
close the casket should we do bits
because we should
what do you got what do you got because
uh i'm not proud of mine so i'd rather
go to yours
oh my god i don't know what i have
really i got oh
man how old is she mom's looking a bit
like caitlyn
oh that's not that's not true
that's it banging our compliment oh you
see this is where it gets interesting
interesting oh what
was the first trans woman who just won
miss america do you see that i did see
that
she was hot would you or she well i
don't know what's downtown but uh
if i'm guessing
wait a minute if there weren't a bikini
i think you would know if there's
something downtown
this is not who i thought it was i take
it all back
that looks like buscemi well i thought
there was i thought she was a brunette
all right oh this is miss universe thank
you
i thought miss america was over by the
way yeah i don't know
who knows something
mississippi what is that oh wow
she looks pretty good there what do we
what do you i don't know what i have
really
because i all my jokes are either
hitting or they're like
all minutia's either hitting is like
part of a chunk i don't really have a
lot of like
in the fetal stage of [ __ ] right yeah
i'm
tightening this set so it's just it's
just a lot of tightening instead of
a whole new idea for sure uh
hold on here we go easy
careful googly is this too
too uh dark so uh i want to do a whole
thing about how like
all the things wow that i might have
done that last week
good one here oh i got one i got one i
need your help with this
and feel free to chime in there sally
because you're actually a victim of this
so you might have a
have a better handle on it but uh
girl girlfriend wants to get married
obviously you know and i got some jokes
about that but i want to do this whole
thing about how
marriage is the only thing that's till
death
marriage in prison are the only things
in life and life yeah but like you can
get a prison sentence
which is like oh i got till death but
marriage is interesting because you
choose
till death you know prison's like oh no
the death sentence that's the worst you
can get
but that's literally what you're
applying for life sentence
life sentence yeah yeah oh good point
death sentence is like the chair
yeah okay life sentence and then
at least with with the jail you have
good behavior
you can get out you can get out you know
wouldn't it be nice if you're like hey
look i've been a great husband for 10
years how about
how about a year-long hall pass yeah
exactly like i should get benefits is
what i'm saying you get good behavior in
prison you don't get good behavior in
marriage
exactly that's interesting yes there's
there's
health benefits like insurance benefits
which we all know you don't give a [ __ ]
about
pockets it's all foreign to me but uh
but other than that
with good behavior you just get i guess
a happier wife you don't get you don't
get any direct purpose yes
where's my perks and i think that would
help marriages to last
if there was some perks because let's be
honest this is
the only problem is you're she's
choosing marriage right
so i know it's for her but you're true
i'm gonna sound like a therapist here
you chose her mark i know but you're
choosing this whereas
you know prison someone maybe it must be
someone saying to you like prison is a
punishment you're like
this is her idea i don't want this it's
gonna be you defending it
right because you know because i think
someone's gonna be like well mark you're
choosing man
yeah good point no she's forcing it
right yeah
pretty much but yeah a defense attorney
to defend the marriage
like to keep her off of you from
getting married like defense attorneys
are arguing oh yeah yeah i need a
restraining order or something but it's
it'd be nice to like get some perks over
the years
you know you stay with the credit card
for a while your what do you call that
it gets bigger
you know you can spend more you know
with a credit longer leash
longer leash i should get more perks and
yeah yeah
honestly you get less perks right yes
you you've been good but the sex goes
down right
sex goes down marriage the perks go down
prison they go on they go up
so it's like [ __ ] up that this
traditional lovey-dovey
matrimony thing has worse perks than
prison is my point
there's something about this
maybe the shower sex definitely more sex
in prison
yeah that's funny there's more sex in
prison
it's only the food's better that's not
true
but you uh
you do get
hmm
oh cell mates selma yeah we're living
together
live together which you know new york
apartments not that much different than
the cell yeah let's be real i'm her
[ __ ]
you have to do you basically you
basically that is kind of funny the
angle of you are her [ __ ]
yeah like you're basically cell mates
with someone who's just much scarier
than you yes yes
you're just like what do you what do you
want to do today right right
you basically find yourself saying that
when you're in a relationship long
enough i do it i want to do whatever you
want to do yeah exactly
no i just want you to be in a good mood
yes they don't beat my ass or kill me or
ruin my life
yeah i'm in the yard you know i'm doing
the yard work
yeah she's basically the warden or or a
scary cell mate
good behavior yeah or some with good
behavior it's hilarious that you're not
even engaged and you're already
comparing it to a [ __ ] prison
terrified it's just what scares you
about it the most
well just because it's like once
you sign it then there's no out there's
no out
i mean there is an out there there is
but it's a nightmare and it's different
you can't be imprisoned been like
this isn't working that's good that's
true yeah this isn't working
ah then they just beat you up that's
true
but it's the fact that like if i'm being
completely honest i think
after you agree to this deal
she can kind of coast interesting yeah
like she's
bringing it because yeah interesting
yeah although
in marriage you don't have to join the
aryan brotherhood just to survive
that's another big one which i could not
but uh you could maybe like we'd be in
the shower they'd be like your penis
looks circumcised be like
[ __ ] run yeah yeah there's no
jewish group in prison that's funny yeah
oh
the former financiers that's our group
we got a couple of madoff's over here
all right we all got a lot of love in
prison oh did he yeah well i mean
he's he's impressive guy to them for
sure
yeah if you're [ __ ] stealing cars and
you meet that guy you're like well
you're the king
yeah good point by the way i watched
another great movie this is another
wreck good time have you seen that great
movie
great movie robert pattinson yeah yeah
the safety brothers
i never heard of it and it i just put it
on it blew my mind it's
so good yeah my friend dina uh hashem
loves it she turned me onto it
and uh yeah it's great the the the
paycheck on that was 11 mil well it got
him adam sandler though in uncut gems
hell yeah because they they proved that
they could make a killer movie so i
think that was like oh
because i think they wanted him from the
get-go and they were like yeah but that
movie just kept you
on the edge of your seat it's it's a
[ __ ] thrill ride
amazing with tension and it's all in new
york and there's no manhattan there's no
skyline it's just [ __ ] queens
it's grizzly and and the idea that like
you're doing it all for your brother and
stuff yeah it's pretty
man and also it's just cool like
pattinson is a really good actor
great actor but people know him from
this movie franchise that he even seems
to hate
which is kind of funny i mean yeah i'm a
fan for sure i love that movie that's my
real wreck
and my gal liked and she hates she's
bored during everything and she was like
loving it yeah it's a thrill ride and it
keeps you
surprised like you're like yes there are
some things where you're like
what big twists big twist it's great my
joke
so i have a few new things that are like
most of my [ __ ] is either
trash or just working so uh
i got a few things but i have one i've
one about like therapy how like therapy
is teaching me
in relationships like when a woman says
i'm upset
to say i understand instead of uh here
we go
you know [ __ ] like that laughing i have
a thing like women will get mad at you
sometimes when they don't
uh when they like when you don't ask
enough like how they're doing but it's
like here's the thing ladies
we always know how you're doing yes we
don't need to ask
it's almost like a weather app where you
don't need to check your phone
sounds
[ __ ] right there's something to me about
the weather app on your phone where you
go
i wish you could get it in advance for
women oh you're like
saturday's gonna be right i'm gonna stay
in the bathroom a little
i'm going to take an extra long [ __ ] and
shower today something there right
that's big you can see it beforehand has
anyone done the weather app
like girlfriend mood bit no i've heard a
lot of weather like
it's it says 50 but it feels like 60.
well then it's 60. you know i've heard
that a lot
that's that's out there but this is good
there should be a
a woman's forecast that's big
do you know what she's going to be like
at 5 or at eight or on tuesday
it's gonna be rough from uh six to seven
but it looks like it's gonna be pretty
chill from eight to ten yeah
looks like we're gonna be all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna sunshine is
similar to your other joke about uh am i
stealing from myself at this point
is that how [ __ ] uh the phone telling
you
you get a call and it tells you what
movie oh that is similar but that that's
different enough
but it's not something that was like a
[ __ ] throw away from our rooftop
special that was just different
thousand times
sally was uh on the roof with me when we
did the rooftop special and literally i
was telling mark right before this it's
like
how much we bicker about like matt wants
he's the director he wants to cool shots
so he's like
we gotta get the sunset the sun is
setting i'm like cool the joke is
bombing
can we get the joke hitting on a
different room all right
but uh man yeah you gotta have that in
the director that's a good bit that's a
good bit something there i love the idea
of a weather man
telling you like okay sarah right now
it's a little rough a little patchy but
later later that's going to be a great
time to hang out and all that like
i love the doppler you know the whole
thing that's gold
there's something there's a lot there
you get the app on your phone you're
like should i wear a jacket tonight and
i should i smile
you know should i ask her about uh
her job interview or whatever that's big
that's what's interesting because your
behavior can impact
you with the weather yes
yeah like act now that's basically
climate change if you're a girlfriend
right great great premise so what do we
got coming up we so we got one in the
bank right so what do gigs do you have
mark
ooh well let's see i'm at the uh toledo
funny bone houston improv
uh i'm all over the place nashville
uh brea california uh philly
helium buffalo helium um
albany dayton funny bone appleton
wisconsin arlington improv
and that should do west palm beach and
florida comedy connection in providence
madison comedy on stage great club
you're there soon i think
i'm there july 8th through 10th
rochester
richmond funny bone portland helium and
laugh boston whatever i got
okc in july 17th
i got uh zany's nashville the 23rd
through the 25th
i've got bellmore new york july 30th
through 31st oh august
yeah baby i got kids show business gary
veeder with me for that one is the
telesis
we got a comedy off broadway in
lexington in august 5th through 7th we
got
kansas city club of uh the club of
kansas city
missouri yeah the 12th through 14th i
heard it's great
we got portland helium 19th through 21st
of august
we've got royal oak michigan we got
uh boston coming up we got [ __ ]
atlanta coming up
dude just added chicago this year
[ __ ]
the den look out for it in uh i believe
october yeah it's the little little tiny
theater i don't know the day
supposed to be very cool got the den in
chicago i'm
pumped going to be there in october we
got the [ __ ]
we added san francisco i know you
[ __ ] we're getting
pushy with that you know i love sf
trying to make phoenix and san diego
work
squeezing [ __ ] in but samrel.com shows
and make sure you uh subscribe to our
new youtube channel a review
yes email us at we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com
and for the patreon patreon.com slash we
might be drunk pod and
and it's worth it man we're dropping
heat on that sally we love having you in
here man
yeah good vibes we got a rye on the way
fat cat
keep a lookout tell your friends let's
all get drunk and do a shot on the road
and uh yeah i think that we'll get so we
gotta get some merch cooking at some
point but uh
things are moving we're gonna maybe try
to make this into a bar
setting i don't know we're doing it i
don't know i don't want to push it i
don't speak out of school but yeah
good stuff keep drinking tell a friend
booze it up go get em
stay classy san diego we might be
drunk we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk